jean luc maréchal est un propriétaire
combler ce passionné d'architecturé a
découvert dans sa maison médiévale des
trésors cachés historique
l'aventuré a débuté en 2007 avec l'achat
du bâtiment et depuis il va de surprise
en surprise
j'ai dit à ma femme on va peut-être
sûrement prouver quelque chose de
singulier et en fait à fatma de mur à
chaque pièce à chaque endroit on trouve
les murs n'en finissent pas de livrer
leurs secrets
surtout dans le domaine des décors
médiévaux parfois c'est par hasard qu'il
fait ces découvertes comme ces fleurs
apparu lors de travaux de maçonnerie
je suis monté sur mon escabeaux je
commence à enlever le plâtre
je fais toujours attention à et je vois
apparaître des petites fleurs derrière
et là je suis resté cloué vraiment cloud
et donc jilib albers et gagnaient la
chaux tu la feras pas ici donc j'ai
renvoyé montmasson sur le poids quatre
décors deux périodes différentes ainsi
été mis à jour dans la bâtisse des
découvertes pas si surprenante à cluny
ville regorgeant de maisons médiévales
les décors peints que l'on a retrouvé
que l'on continue à trouver dans les
maisons sont répartis aussi bien dans de
très riches demeures que dans des
maisons très modeste donc on est dans
une maison modeste qui peut remonter au
13e siècle et on trouve donc toute une
série de décor jean-luc va poursuivre
son travail de fourmi pour le grand
plaisir des chercheurs qui encourage les
propriétaires à sonder leurs maisons
quand on a la chance d'avoir une de ces
maisons
en fait on est dépositaire d'un
patrimoine et d'un héritage et lorsque
l'on sait que on les auscultant on ne
bouscule an passé vieille dame est au
contraire en leur demandant de nous
parler du passé on peut trouver beaucoup
de témoins et bien on le fait avec une
fille
quatre décors deux périodes différentes
ont ainsi été mises au jour dans la
bâtisse des découvertes pas si
surprenante à cluny ville regorgeant de
maisons médiévales